hello everyone and welcome to another
big clash from the round four of the
tata steel uh chess tournament 2022 it's
a former 2800 member shakhtar mahmoud
versus uh uh well a member of the next
candidate tournament uh the number one
polish player young shisht of duda it's
a it's a pretty uh pretty crazy game a
lot of turnarounds you guys are gonna
enjoy it so uh let's check it out we
have some time to check up on uh some
other games as today is the rest day so
round five will only resume tomorrow uh
so uh mamadyarov with the white pieces
opens with d4
sorry about that uh we have knight to f6
by duda uh c4 we have e6 knight to f3
and the d5 the queen gamut's decline is
on the board uh we have knight to c3 and
now c5 striking in the center going for
the semitarge defense we have c captures
on d5 and now not knight captures or
recaptures but rather c captures on d4
uh this is uh somewhat rare uh but um uh
lately uh the the players uh wielding
the black pieces uh in positions like
these have been starting to use this
even in top tier tournaments because uh
well modern engines like lelache zero
showed that it is okay to play this with
black uh you'll see what i mean for
example queen captures on the 4e
captures on d5 and now e4
uh striking uh
in the center with the idea of opening
up the the d file if captures then we're
going to capture on d8 and well just
bereft black off of opening of castling
privileges
and that this was considered a problem
before for example queen capture 78 with
czech king captures and now just knight
to g5 and this is looking
pretty good for white yes black is up a
pawn but white can always pick up this
pawn you're threatening the f7 pawn and
black defends this with bishop to e6
this is how
this line is played and now of course
you don't go after the pawn you pick up
the bishop uh so you create some
imbalance in the position black now has
a double e pawn you have the bishop pair
and you are very happy with this but
motor engines said that this is okay for
black and now everyone is using it
against everyone so here bishop to g5
pinning the knight attacking the king
with h6 and now a queen side castle
which tempo the king is in check and now
king the e7 yeah it looks a bit weird to
block in your dark square bishop like
this but the problem is if you go king
to e8 you just give white a free tempo
on that pawn on e6 for example we're
going to capture here captures and
bishop to c4 put pressure here and now
you can waste another tempo by moving
the king or if you want to play
something like e5 we're just going to
play knight to d5 and now this is
hanging
this is hanging and it's just a very
very hard position for for black to
handle so instead after castle king the
e7 this is uh the top move in the
position we have bishop captures on f6 g
captures and knight captures on e4
winning the pawn back and now the
material is equal but as you see
uh the position is we have bishops of
opposite colors so if everything else
gets traded off it's going to be a draw
pretty much uh but one thing is that uh
white has two pawn islands and black has
three pawn islands so white should be a
little bit better here uh here we have
f5 challenging this night here and so
far they've been following the game uh
move by move uh that uh
timor jabo and magnus cross and played
in the new inches classic in 2021 uh the
game that ended in a draw where knight
to c5 was played but here we have knight
to g3 by mom yarov and it is now as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game so here we have h5 uh continuing to
advance this pawn h4 might
get this knight to an even more uh
well
unpleasant square uh bishop to c4 and
now knight to d7 so just continuing
development we have kinked a b1 a nice
prophylactic move as the rook the c8
might be coming so you do not want your
king on c1
knight to e5 challenging the bishop
bishop back to b3 and now king to f6
just improving the position of your king
rook h the e1 white nicely doubles not
doubles but develops the rooks on the uh
open d and semi open e file and now rook
to e8 we need to defend this pawn so our
knight can move
we have bishop to a for attacking the
rook and now rook to e7 and now finally
h4 by movie are not allowing duda to
push h4 himself
uh we have knights to g6 now we can move
the knight uh and rook to d4 and this
rook to d4 is uh is a very nice plane by
mama darav not only is he preventing any
ideas with this knight coming to f4 also
you're clearing the d1 square for the
bishop so bishop to d1 will go after
that h5 pawn so what can duda do about
this well just rook the c7 he doesn't
care about this threat because it would
be premature to go bishop to d1 here we
can just develop our bishop for example
here once the rook moves we're going to
play b5 chase away the rook and now even
after this for example captures with
check
we can just capture back with the rook
and now for example rook captures on c5
rook captures on c5 bishop captures on
h5 knight captures on h4 we're going to
play g3 uh challenge the knight and now
well the material is equal but black and
for example play f4 open up and attack
towards the bishop and we've uh well we
haven't really achieved anything with
this bishop to d1 idea so first sorry
bishop to d1 idea so first we have
bishop to b3 again putting pressure on
this e6 pawn and now you could defend it
with uh rook to c6 but the duda goes for
this very aggressive e5 move so he
attacks this rook uh we have rook to d8
rook the d6 of course is impossible as
the bishop covers this square so rook to
d8 and now finally we have knight
captures on h4 uh and now what can
momodaro do here well you could play
rook to h1 kick away the knight and then
you could pick up maybe on h5 but
instead he goes for rook to e8 he really
wants to go for this rook the e6 check
and create some complications so knights
the g6 and now guarding this pawn and we
have rook the e6 with check and now the
very bold king to g5 uh and now bishop
the c2 going after the f5 pawn but now
duda has a brilliant brilliant winning
move but it's not it's not the
problematic to see this move the the
problem lies in seeing all of the
variations that lead to a win so here of
course the move is h5 we are not only uh
uh asking whites to capture on f5 we are
asking white what are you even playing
here because uh if you capture on f5 yes
you're guarding that knight with the
bishop but we're just gonna capture the
bishop after game captures we're gonna
play
uh king captures on f5 and we have a
bishop and the knight for a rook this
will be
this will be winning for black so what
can you do here well momidaro finds a
very very tricky idea he plays rook to
e3 point being that after h captures on
g3 we can play rook captures on g3 with
check and now after let's say king f4 uh
you don't go after the knight to play
rook f3 check king g5 and now rook
captures on f5 with check king to h6 and
now rook f captures an e5 and you get
this position where yes okay
black still has a bishop in the knight
so black is up a piece but the position
of the king is just terrible and this
will be unplayable for black also you
have to connect it past pawn so all in
all this should be winning for white uh
so instead after rook to e3 duda does
not play that duda plays e4 uh but uh
he uh well sort of disconnects this
bishop and knight controlling the f5
square but the actual winning move for
duda here believe it or not is bishop to
g7 and who would play this it's such a
such a crazy move to play but this this
is winning now and now you don't have a
good move because we already discussed
that if the knight captures an f5 rook
captures and c2 is just winning for
black so you're gonna have to move the
knight and now the problem is there's uh
rook h the c8 threatening the bishop and
once the bishop moves for example knight
f4 attacks the knight you can't move the
knight because of rook the c1 checkmate
and now duda is completely winning
but i mean
here who plays
bishop to g7 here it's a completely
crazy move but it but unnecessary one if
you want to win this so here e4 was
played and now we have finally knight
captures on f5 this is still better for
duda but uh he it does uh give him a
medal of some chances king captures an
f5 now rook 3 captures on e4 threatening
all sorts of discoveries here so uh dude
a ghost for rook captures on c2 just to
give you an example if you play
something like bishop to g7 we cl we
quickly check made the black king for
example king g4 rook captures on g6 king
f4 and now rook to f5 will be checkmate
the pawn covers the e3 square so instead
here uh just rook captures and see do we
have to eliminate this nasty bishop here
king captures and now bishop the c5 and
here okay it's still a bishop and knight
for a rook but now that king is in a
really uh really tough spot uh and
especially since mamiyara finds the only
good move for him and that is of course
pawn to g4 with check with the idea that
if the king moves we're going to push f4
and if h captures on g3 we just play f
captures on g3 and well there simply
isn't all that much
you can do here g4 check is still coming
and it will be
it will be hard to defend this knight
and g6 so instead after g4 uh do that
right king to g5 but now we go after the
king f4 with check and now if you
capture on g4 we just captured the
knight here so knight captures on f4 was
played but even this doesn't help we
have rook six the e5 with check and now
the bishop falls so you either give up
the knight or the bishop uh king
captures on g4 and now rook captures on
c5 so king to f3 uh now okay dude is
down the exchange but he still has the
past h pawn so uh he should be perfectly
fine here rook to b4 uh as the rook was
attacked by the king and now you have to
play knight to g2 for a very very
specific reason uh but dude just
continued pushing with h3 this is move
36 they still have to make four more
moves to reach time control so of course
uh they have to hurry yeah but now the
position is completely winning for
mamadarov uh he adoda allowed it and
there's nothing he can do about it if
mamadara finds the move of course so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this elusive idea that duda missed
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well move that starts with a check
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is rook the c3 check
the only move that wins for mom and dad
so congratulations to everyone who found
this and now you simply don't have a
don't have a good square uh king to g4
was played you have to keep an eye on
this knight but now rook c to c4 and it
seems like
so what you're going to capture the
knight i'm just going to queen here the
problem is you can't and to give you an
example if h2 we capture on f4 with
check and after king g3 there's rook g4
with check and now king f2
we play rook to h4 that's the problem we
uh attack the rook and also guard the
queening square so there really isn't
anything better than just queening here
and we're gonna trade captures captures
but now uh yes for the moment the
material is equal but we're gonna
eliminate both of these pawns there's
nothing black can do about this and the
white will have two connected past pawns
for example this this this this this and
now now even this you can even double
your pawns this is still winning uh the
black king is too too far off from from
the action to to do anything about this
uh past
a pawn
so after rook c to c4 this doesn't work
so rook to f8 was played guarding the
knight but now rook captures on b7 with
the idea of rook to h7 just putting the
rook behind the pass pawn and all of a
sudden there's nothing for duda to do
here h2 was played now comes rook to h7
and here king to g3 but now mamedyarov
just cold-bloodedly uh played king to b3
and he was in this position on mu 41 uh
that young shisht of duda resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so there's nothing you can do uh
that pawn is never queening if you move
the king for example king g2 just rook c
to check and we're gonna pick up this
pawn you can't really move anything and
there really isn't a good move you can
play here so after king b3 he resigned
and a a wonderful victory for shahid
mahmoud in round four of the 2021 tata
steel tournament
uh so tough break for duda but uh
uh yeah i mean um like i said mom ya'll
is a former member of the 2800 it
doesn't matter if you
uh if you i have a winning position
mamijaro will give you hell uh until he
he actually resigns and it was uh i
thought the the uh quote above the board
by bruce pandelfini that was appropriate
here mahmoud had to complicate in order
to get out of all the mess and in the
end he even ended up winning the game
so what does this mean for the standings
after seven rounds have been played
let's check it out uh sorry these are
the wrong standings let me just uh
uh find the the actual ones
uh because i did prepare them uh yeah
this should be it okay no idea how that
one came there
uh there we go so these are the
standings after four rounds uh the
tournament uh uh is uh uh led by uh
gujarati with three out of four points
so incredibly impressive tournament um
uh with with the current uh rating
performance of twenty nine hundred and
twenty seven then with two and a half
points we have andrey sipenko magnus
crossing in shakhtar mahmud uh and uh
sorry and rihar rapport and jordan fun
forest um uh all on two and a half then
with two points youngshi dududa fabiano
corona
with a point and a half anish giri
daniel dubo and sam shankland and sergey
karyakin and with uh 0.
zero zero and a half points uh niels
grandelius so it's uh okay aside from
grand daley who is a bit lower rated
than the rest of the field uh it's uh
hard to imagine for example karjakin in
in um uh 13th place or maybe dubois and
geary in 10 and 11 but it's such a
strong tournament that anyone can be in
any place it's just uh it's just the way
it is
uh so yeah that's the game those were
the standings hope you guys uh enjoyed
that uh i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to busa and i would like
to thank frederick vitter ellen sweater
joseph dumas and francis ayer for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
tata steel chess tournament until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day